has just come to us from government  figures to be keeping an eye on how many  children are out of school  the numbers were in the low hundreds of  thousands  but it now appears that over the last  week  more than one million children in  england  alone were out of school due to covert  19 related reasons this is  from the government so this could be  that they have been pinged or it could  be that somebody in their bubble  uh was also possibly pinged um but we  are there  has also been uh reports anecdotally of  parents taking their children out of  school  because they didn't want the children to  to be on that at-risk  list before the schools break up in just  a week or so's time  um because it would of course jeopardize  potential summer holidays but more than  a million children in england  out of school last week due to covert 19  related  reasons